chief Washington correspondent major
Garrett is here for more on last night's
debate and the next one ahead major as
Edie pointed out it looked like Biden
did better last night but it wasn't
entirely smooth what is his camp thanks
so talking to Democrats last night go
with this metaphor with me last night he
came in as a plane losing altitude and
airspeed not a good thing in politics or
avionics but two of the engines kicked
in so two of the four are now going yes
like a dramatic movie so he's stabilized
yeah but if I was out in the plane I'd
still be interviewed still be nervous
that's right if you're a Biden
supporting like okay we've stabilized
but this is not the kind of wringing
performance on specifics I think at a
macro level he kind of said all right
I've stabilized but on his his history
you know and his vision for the future
he's got a lot of work to do
Cory Booker and Kamala Harris were
attacking on lanes that are important to
them in South Carolina predominantly
african-american voters are currently
preferring Joe Biden over the two of
them that's why you saw such intense
concentration and they had a vernacular
along those lines as well yeah I mean
the kool-aid line I would say one thing
about last night a good night for 70s
popular household Browns Horrocks you
know he never really delivered Cory
Booker who delivered that great line
never really delivered an answer to the
question so he needed to sort of prop up
his sales in this debate did he sure I
mean it was a nice deflection it was
very very well crafted Cory Booker has a
Newark story there are things that
happen on his watch that are very
positive in terms of new investment and
new businesses and some jobs but crime
and criminal justice is not a strong
suit of his time as mayor of Newark and
Joe Biden has this long history now he
could say in the 1990s when this
legislation was passed we had aid in
serious crime problem in this country
were there unintended consequences yes
there were I've learned from them but
what I'm surprised with Joe Biden on
this issue is not to say look you go
back to the statistics this was
bipartisan and it was a huge issue yeah
he doesn't seem even comfortable with
that basic part of his own legislative
history that's why he's got two engines
not for Pamela Harris's record also came
under fire last night did she lose
ground Kamala Harris
figured out last night what it means to
be something that is in it yeah he was
she's a player and yeah now I guess
flargan your record now is you know for
scrutiny and you can get harsh attacks
and equate a minute where did that come
from that's part of this process and for
this very same community
african-american community her record as
a prosecutor attorney general in
California is a legitimate issue and
again she was less comfortable there
then you might have expected for someone
who did so well in the first debate
being a prosecutor she was less
comfortable being someone who was a
defense witness so as Eddie
O'Keefe pointed out only seven people
are qualified for the next debate I
think it's clear from Latin you'll see
larger number of last night's field in
the next round than we did on the first
night I think a lot of the people in the
first night are gonna fall out
Andrew yang and Michael Bennett I think
did themselves some good Christian
Gerald Brown kirsten gillibrand did
herself some good I think all of those
have a potential to get into that next
debate not so much the first night all
right major Garrett the man who knows